you want to guess when this thing is
valid too on this it's probably only
supposed to be 5 years so what do you
think this in 2019 so 2024 what do you
think 2029 what do you think I'm going
to say even crazy I'm going to say like
some 2030 or something uh how about the
year 3000 sck
around hey tties welcome to another
episode of Dum people Town population
you population estada Chris EST is with
usud thanks for being here such a fan of
yours we got to just hang out with you
you did our tag it show at the story a
lot of fun you were amazing dude this
guy hit the stage with such energy you
came at the perfect time in the show and
you just fire crush City yeah that was a
lot of fun it was just fun to it was
such a fun show to do and then for you
guys to come up and give us tags and
like it's collaborative it's a very
unique show and it's very Co I feel like
that's the way you operate in the comedy
world too I mean look you have an
amazing show on Hulu that is so good
collaborative with so many great people
but that's kind of your Vibe though you
like to work with other people I do I
even writing jokes like a lot of the
comics I came up with occasionally we
don't do it as often anymore but we will
meet at like a diner and and we used to
put on a timer we used to put on if it
was four of us we do 15 minutes each and
then just be like what are you working
on what are youing ideas that's who this
guy is yeah and then we' like oh what
about this or what if you say it that
direction so it's like I love it that's
the essence of that show yeah which is
kind of the essence of this podcast too
like we all have a steering wheel we can
all go driving and the world is dumber
and we have stories and Dan's going to
get ready this was sented by Brew pound
at Brew pounder thanks bud thanks so
much for sending or could be a woman I
don't know C pounder couple on first
date breaks into church to play piano
it's a great first hey that's a you're
either like having a wild insane night
or you're like the most wholesome
criminals or your boyfriend's Billy
Joel or Julio e glac he's like he's like
no but Billy jol he's like I'll do it
I'll do it but I'm only playing River of
Dreams I'm only playing River that's not
a good down Easter Alexa I want Angry
Young Man what a date I mean whose idea
was that though that's a dude idea
that's a dude idea that's a dude idea
because there's no exit strategy no
woman is like hey what we doing tonight
do you want to break into this church
and do what play piano deep cut for scar
fans this is takes place in
Hendersonville Tennessee Henderson
WKRN a couple's first date in
Hendersonville Tennessee turned into a
church burglary and then a trip to jail
by the way Church burglar is a great
like like indie rock band SC SC SCA band
Church Burg the burglar really you could
hear that bass and the horns a lot of
bass driven lot of horn
yeah lot of checkered
Vans can I ask you guys this a genuine
question do you think SCA will ever come
back totally I into mainstream I know on
some level never in the way that it used
to be that like real big fish Scot Big
Fish think it will you think it will so
the fun Goldfinger real big fishy B
bossones uh great song great songit the
impression that I get that song
phenomenal and they had a guy who just
danced in the band he didn't sing he
didn't play skanking guy skanking on
stage man I love it Mustard Plug Mustard
Plug that's right Aquabats could you
argue that could you argue that Sublime
bridge the gap between Scot and REE I
mean no doubt in Sublime no doubt is a
scy band right yeah yeah yeah I I think
Sublime really bridged that I think
Sublime was the one that you're like it
was the cool one like you know dangerous
dangerous from Long Beach Long Beach
drugs dog you got a dog running around
they were great okay uh turned into a a
church burglar that's right police in
Hendersonville said the two people were
on a first date when they broke into the
Indian Lake Peninsula church at around
what time Thursday morning real quick
when do you think they're doing this
they're on a date on a Thursday breaking
into a church on a Thursday 2 in the
morning 2. 2 A.M 2 a.m. what do you
think i' like to imagine that they got
hammered and they went Sunday morning
thinking it was Saturday
morning where's every everybody yeah you
guys are on dates too yeah everybody's
dressed so
nice uh did everybody guess I'll I
didn't guess I think uh this I think
this happened at 4: in the morning
they'd broke in around 12:50 a.m. wow
Thursday morning part the couple canest
to the crime police said claiming they
broke into the church because they
wanted to play the piano and thought a
church might have one they could use
that checks out good that logic checks
out no no here's what he said I want to
get you somewhere where you can mess
with my organ she didn't understand and
now they're in a church and now they're
playing the church organ it's like this
isn't what I had in mind a Christian bad
boy like a youth pastor gone wild yes
hey did you see that documentary about
the C oh the that's I just thought you
guys have watch Pastor gone wild no h
song documentary have you seen that yet
have you seen oh I mean it's a he was
like the rock star he was like a rockar
Justin Bieber's P yes I've heard of this
guy okay you know that guy and he like
his crazy downfall but then his kind of
it's an interesting it's a crazy and
they used him and he enjoyed it oh they
used him in such a bad way those
Australians who were like part of the
old surveillance footage from outside
the church shows the two pulling up to
the church in a sometimes you just know
things about people based on what they
drive 2004 Ford Mustang they're oh [__]
Glory old Ford Mustang souped up yeah
just put new just put oh Siri's talking
to me the male can be seen with a
surprise smile SM on his face when they
try the door and find it unlocked okay I
don't want to blame the victim here but
I know you're a church yeah you still
have to lock the door lock the doors
right lock the doors yes thank you so do
you remember when the crazy floods
obviously the floods happened in uh was
in Houston yeah hurricane Henry and Joel
Joel oin who like mega church mega
church took over which they met where
the Rockets used to play baset that's
right so we and we went up to it to like
see this mega church they would not take
in any I'm like this is the point at
which you allow people to sleep in
that's what a church is for you set up
lost their houses this is an arena and
then there was like a dude like Max The
Mattress King he stepped in he stepped
in I knew a comic from Houston really
funny guy named Barry labac and he has a
joke about that how o didn't step in but
the mattress king did that's right
that's right now who do you believe in
right right The Mattress King The
Mattress King sh out Mattress King uh
after entering the church they stayed to
play the piano for how many minutes how
long you think they were in there
friends 45 minutes what do you think I'm
going to say 30 okay I think 120 Minutes
one of you is exactly right M they were
in there for 30 minutes both subjects
admitted to detectives that they were
looking for a piano to play because they
both play the piano they knew churches
had pianos so they were looking for an
unlocked Church to play a piano just say
you're drunk how
many yeah like how drunk are they just
you know how drunk they are by the
amount of times they say piano yeah yeah
yeah yes for pianoo four times say piano
four times in that you're looking for a
place at a he play piano piano I play
piano don't you play piano tell you play
piano so we wanted to find a church to
have oh you don't get it a piano
hilarious but you're right they they
need to lock their doors I'm just saying
overnight okay like you are you can open
be so trusting right this is all uh said
by detective this is what I want to say
to churches be more cynical Steven fry
of the Hendersonville police police in
Hendersonville Tennessee said the couple
admitted to quote acting dumb police
said the two uh also stole four Bibles
and two drumsticks when they left I'm
hoping ice cream I know it's not but you
want to be little ice cre con with the
nuts and the
chocolate to the end it's just mean two
Bibles yeah how many bibles do you need
four Bibles and what we weren't stealing
these we were borrowing these and we
just wanted to spread the good word well
so we a family friend of ours owned the
Christian bookstore Glory B uh rip Glory
B glory and if they ever had someone in
there that they thought were shoplifting
or like stealing Bibles they just let
them because they were like if that
person needs this religion or feels a
place that that's what they want to
believe in we're going to like arrest
them for wanting to be Christian did you
go to church as a kid uh we grew up like
Catholic but my mom was like growing up
my mom was like we're poor we have to
work we don't need to go to church okay
we need the hours we need the
hours the valley you grew up in the
valley no I grew up in in South Central
South Central that's right oh that's
right that's right but uh this this is
like the good natured version of like
those black uh black metal kids do you
do you know these in Sweden and nor
heavy metal black metal kids like they
were into like black metal they were
burning churches in the 9s yeah oh this
sounds familiar yeah it they made a
movie of it called Lords of chaos it was
a documentary too this is the very
good-natured version right yeah they're
like what we're just playing the mve the
drum kid around okay so the drumsticks
is the worst part about this whole the
Bibles that's going to piss off that's
going to piss off a 70-year-old man in
about 8 hours I put them in the cubby
hole I know where they
are they steal four Bibles two
drumsticks the surveillance video shows
the female picking up a church
collection plate police say she took it
as a souvenir okay right that you should
not be taking the church collection PL
that off of that thing they're also
heard on surveillance camera talking
about their shock at discovering a piano
based on what you said why are you
shocked oh my God babe bab literally
here it is this is the exchange wasted
they were can I remind you this is a
first date first date yes first date
blind date do you think your family your
family into
Christmas you know the couple that gets
arrested together stays together go
right up until one gets taken to booking
and the others until until they throw
each other under the bus in
interrogation here's the exchange from
the female I found a piano this is what
they said on the camera I'm so shocked
we found one at the first church I know
right are there and there are so many
more churches I was ready to go to oh my
God by the way I know right is I you
we've all said I know right is this guy
being like are we going to get together
is this going to happen they're just
like I found a piano I'm so shy they're
drunk 2004 Mustang you know they peeled
in what did they play that's what I want
to know what song Oh I would love I
would love to know the song with the
regular in the OR meatloaf would be
great home sweet home that's how much I
feel the church pastor discovered the
break-in that morning and called the
police detectives and Patrol offers work
to identify the suspects using
surveillance footage police were able to
identify the females 2004
Mustang P at that way a bad they quickly
found both suspects from there the two
later conest and surrendered The Stolen
the stolen Church items they quote this
is from detective fry they just admitted
it was dumb probably should not have
done it they knew it was a mistake
inherently they did not apologize and
you were right the first date Dynamic of
like yeah I guess I'll get this is what
you're into like I mean the
maybe um Indian Lake Peninsula Church
administrative Pastor Drew altum said he
hopes the two people at least learn
something from their actions I would
tell them don't let this incident Define
you Adam said he's grateful for the
police for their quick response I will
ask you guys this how old is the couple
they are the same age okay same age are
you going uh one you know both are
recently divorced trying to live it up
2004 Mustang
and it's hers and she drove and she
drove or did she say to him you can
drive this if you want right what she
say I have cataracts I'll steer you tell
me what color the light is okay so how
there's a lot of questions here you know
what I'm going to say 42 42 years old
that's a good one I'm going to say 26 54
54 yeah we got out of Story one on this
before I hand it over to Jason when I
come back I will tell you what I'm up to
and we'll hear what Chris Estrada is up
to as well but I can tell you guys that
the couple who steal drumsticks
collection plates four Bibles shocked
that they found a piano when that's what
they were looking for crushed a version
of
Allentown
are 20 years old oh my God Dan I almost
said 19 years so young So Young Chris
and I went the opposite all right we're
going to take a break we'll come back
and find out what Dan's doing and what
Chris is doing it's DB people town with
the great Chris Estrada we'll be right
back
hey guys welcome back to the show before
we get into how you can follow Chris and
we're going to talk a lot about this
fool uh Dan tell us when people can see
you you got stuff coming out you got the
W think in February I should be
announcing it soon if I haven't already
but go to Daniel van.com I'm going to be
doing a weekend in uh DC and then I have
other dates that I will be doing through
March and April Pacific Northwest might
be going to uh Hawaii
Wy ke and then do Kawaii
SOC the official pronunciations of those
W yeah yeah Wii uh I will be uh doing
shows everywhere leading up to the
special which I think is going to drop
in April the rose gold hour so you'll
still have a chance to see that and I'm
probably forgetting stuff but if you go
there you'll see my brand new website
thanks to Green I Ivy Collective I just
want to shout out a good towy who said
I'll fix your website for you her name's
Aon she's awesome I love it uh Chris is
with us and if haven't seen this fool
and this fool uh do you get that brought
up all the time you're going to love
this fool and yeah and this next fool
he's on the
show in so here's what I love about it
as a person who didn't grow up in that
it like to me as I'm watching it I'm
like okay this shares a lot of really
great stuff with reservation dogs which
I love too I feel like those shows are
very hand inand but I'm like I love that
this is in uh culture and sort of the
way you were brought up that I was not
and yet I have full access to it that's
we try to make it so we try to not make
it too referential in a way we try to
make it like incredibly specific but in
a way that like the problems are as
universal as anything else completely
achiev that somebody like do with
Frankie who's so good at that sort of
style as well like the dress up gang
makes the biggest things out of the
small smallest in and finding that
Nuance in relationship and everything
else because when you you know this is
sort of happens with Chicago you say
Chicago or you say south central people
have these first like thoughts about it
and to go like no this is about
relationship and about people it's not
it's it's life here and growing up here
and perceived Notions of who people are
or what they should be yeah we we were
really inspired by the movie Friday do
you guys remember Friday and how much of
a like kind of like you didn't have to
be from that world to really like enjoy
that movie and the way we like pitched
it was always like Friday but directed
by the Coen brothers so we can make the
show a little offbeat
like cinematic
and man I truly it's like if you're
thinking and I know people certainly as
you go into the break if people don't
know the show already if you're not on
it like get on it binge and watch the
whole damn thing and catch up some timer
on the holiday are you guys makeing more
what's the story oh we're waiting to
here we're we got we can do this you
guys we can make this happen so everyone
watch it and and let Hulu know that more
needs to be made just because yeah Power
of literally just at and then company
this show is amazing this show needs it
really goes a long way CU they expect us
to say it yeah they expect us to say it
of course they're going to be like of
course you want it to happen right I
always say one audience member is the
equivalent of 10 creative people in
terms of like in terms just saying I
want to see this cuz it's indicative of
like an audience you know did you get
that from people who just you know fans
who found the show and found you and
they're like oh my God you just you
totally captured my experience or you
yeah I get a lot of people you know what
so funny I get random people who I
wouldn't expect like got a message from
this guy who was like I'm polish I moved
here to the states when I was like in my
teens and my mom's a janitor and we have
an episode where the mom character
steals toilet paper from her job such a
great episode and she was like he he was
telling me he goes I really relate to it
because like my mom was a janitor and
she stole cleaning supplies from her job
toilet paper all the time so just like
you be surprised who it resonates with
Yeah the more personal it is the broader
it is yeah so yeah I always get really
nice like people always like it really
resonates with me all types of people so
I love it again we grew up as Jews in St
Louis and I'm like watching the show and
I'm like man I get everything that's
going on here fully connect with it and
then of course you have like crazy
character like Frankie's character that
is like unique and you haven't seen it
before it's also okay to be like this is
a world I don't know they're sharing
information to me about this how I feel
when I watch Like Ramy like I know
that's a great that's a perfect example
of a world that I don't know and I'm
like yeah this is great even the British
office when the first British office
came out and they're like making fun of
a town nearby like slow and I'm like yes
that's where they are they make fun of
the next town I'm like yeah like I like
I don't know any of these references but
I get what they're saying but I get it
because I've done that there is a there
is a that town in our life I love it all
right this fool check it out anything
else where people can see you live stuff
and whatnot I'm going to be at American
Comedy Co in San Diego great uh December
21st to the 23rd so right before
Christmas yeah there you go there's your
Christmas present down there in San
Diego go see him and I'm sure those
shows will sell out so get your tickets
now love it all right this was sent in
by carlen
mcder car wonderful here's the headline
Court spectator jailed for laughing at
Jury from Gallery during and I won't
tell you how big the uh the price was
during a tax trial so guy in the gallery
yeah why is it called called peanut
gallery that is supposedly racist
actually really way we're not supposed
to say peanut gallery anymore what is
how what do we know I think it maybe had
to do with I don't know so I don't want
to speak out of school but I definitely
think it like look it thinking slave
peanut farmer type of a thing really
yeah so we can't say peanut gallery we
can't say Gallery i' rather so this if I
go get a jury this fool jury duty
summons you're like as Comedians and
people we our creative time were like
this is the worst thing that could ever
happen they're not even a jury right I
know
this laughing at the people in the jury
and it's making people uncomfortable so
the person in the gallery gets jailed
there are people who just go to watch
court it's very the jury and you're
looking at people out in the court
you're like what are you doing man how
boring is your life I you could just
watch Jud Judge Judy Judge matis can so
many when we caught shoplifters um when
I worked at Marshall Fields you'd have
to go to court you know oh were you lost
prevention yes oh I love lost prevention
people I wrote I've written a whole
pilot about it dude nobody takes their
job more serious job CR of my pilot
because I was just in college but they
were all waiting to be Chicago police
officers exactly this is stepping stone
this is their n get this guy to
Executive produce that pilot and it gets
made I worked at JC Penney and I worked
at a department right under loss
prevention and we had to check in
employees bags and whatnot but L
prevention people serious serious dude I
I heard a story one time where was one
guy caught this guy and he was you want
to do this [__] here you take that to
the other town like you don't he had
like our prevention is better than their
he had civic pride wrapped into his job
it was a guy I think he worked in
monabell and he goes you want to do this
[__] in montabello you take that [__] to
e we don't do
that that's so funny I love it kill oh
my God but you have to like so any I was
just saying there there was sometimes
where you'd sit there and be like this
is a show for free there is some crazy
[__] that happens but how loud is your
laugh we've all experienced somebody
especially if you're shooting a special
where you're like I you you can't laugh
like it's as a comedian you've gotten
those laughs where you go God your laugh
is so annoying I wish you didn't find me
funny right yes I wish so how are your
all over my special this is Robert dairo
and Kate fear that's a level of laughter
it can't be once right no no and it has
to be Sinister and
pointed yeah at the movie theater so
weird all right a man spotted of course
it's a man who was spotted laughing at
the jury during a complex I won't tell
you how much this tax fraud trial has
been jailed for contemp of court
construction worker Michael moan not
going to tell you his age are you there
was seen pointing at the jurors and
chuckling to a friend as judge Steven
Everett was finishing his summing up of
14 weeks of evidence at Chester Crown
Court so he's roasting the jury to his
buddy that's fun two jurors who saw moam
pointing at them were said to be
obviously affected of course and we're
looking down at their feet as they later
filed in and out of the jury box well
cuz he was making fun of their feet so
maybe it's like intimidating or
something like you can't yeah he's the
worst Intimidator in the world the
person no one else is supposed to know
you're intimidating this person that's
right on the very like yeah
you mhm [__] you but then both people
look around you go like that yeah you
don't do it anything they don't laugh
out loud I like that he points at them
and he does
this the finger eyelasses these nerds
here you want one of these what's up
nerd if I may your honor moan was asked
to leave the courtroom by staff but he
initially refused to go and then
declined to give up his name all right
bro if someone's like you're bothering
the jurors get out of here and if he's
like oh sorry I sor laughing with my
friend he doesn't go to jail right Dan
this is the thing I've talked about from
when the years working door in
downtown I used to think some guys
wanted a fight until I realized that
some men want to lose a fight right they
want some men want to get punched in the
face there's exact I have a buddy like
this and then cuz I don't think he grew
up like in a way that he's been punched
in the face before and he wants that I I
go dude you're being self destructive
you don't want this I go you know what
cuz now it's kind of selfish of you cuz
now you're putting this bouncer in a
situation where he might get in trouble
because you want to be a martyr right
right someone who can't swim jumping in
the water like we talked about the other
day because now someone has to save you
and they might drink I feel like this
guy went to court to get arrested just
like he went a guy goes to a bar to get
he's like I'm a bad guy I deserve to be
behind bars what can I do God I wish you
was that self-aware it's just probably
they're so stupid no Dan's right cuz
listen the judge asked asked him to
leave immediately he answered back you
ought to be patient what does that mean
the judge my you ought to be patient
what does that mean this is like the
worst episode of Impractical Joker like
s is in his ear being like tell tell
tell them you say something that doesn't
make sense quick you know at first at
first hearing that story I was like you
know what maybe they're being too hard
on this this guy's an
[__] deserves what he gets yeah this
is the prequel to 60 days in all right
so he was subse subsequently arrested
and it was disco discovered that he had
been at the court for a different trial
over unrelated public orders matter so
this guy is a public maybe he's pissed
off about his thing and he's now going
to disrupt this other court now if I'm
the two jurors who he's laughing at I
then go to his trial yes and laugh at
him well here you want to hear you want
to kind or I just I don't laugh at him I
just show up in his Gallery front row
and just be like stare at him yeah
nodding do you want to be confused about
how you feel about this guy hand of
elmir Port Cheshire who lost his left
leg in an accident in 2021 now I'm on
his side come on was jail for 21 days
after being found guilty of contempt of
court now I'm upset with it all right uh
Everett said that this happens a lot
just because life did you bad you don't
get to be an [__] you lost a lot lost
leg you're going to lose a court he
didn't have a leg to stand on in
that guys that's a show folks thank you
so much we'll be here not getting better
he was really leaning we won't he only
had one leg to stand up right he only
one leg stand ever said that if jury
members he was hopping mad no come on
ever said that if uh the jury members
had asked themselves why he had been
pointing and laughing at them it could
have led to the trial being abandoned
right he described mahan's actions as
quote threatening and arrogant the trial
itself was part of a criminal proceeding
that had been going on for how many
years oh my gosh sick 6 years from
Daniel what say two two 12 years 12
years of Tri you're closest r 10 years W
that it cost the taxpayers hundreds of
thousands of dollars the judge told
Monahan it's important that everybody
understands that the court these people
have been on jury duty for 10 years is a
place where people have to be oh my God
IM oh my God damn that's a that's a
weird well for the past decade I've been
a juror you could do 10 seasons of that
sitcom like the office but it's jury
dude jur number three if you do not
believe in oh how great was that joke in
uh in jury duty the oh no in have you
seen that show by the way jury duty Mar
brilliant Mars's so good another Hulu
show uh watch them both uh no but the uh
the the what was the the joke the name
of the show that the movie she was doing
on 30 Rock the rule the
rural the
rural
rural that joke will never not be
funny okay so you've been in a writer's
room so you're in a writer's room and
there are the jokes that like you make
the writers go just in a writer room
this whole last couple weeks and there
are jokes that just make you crazy and
you have to be smart enough to know that
like this is just for us the rural jur
is a joke that I thought probably
cracked up and it made it in and we all
love it think like weekly I think about
that brilant so the Jud it's judge from
one hand it's important that everyone
understands that the court is a place
where people have to behave of course
it's a courtroom people do not in court
we're heading down uh Aldi to Anarchy
and that's a problem I found your
behavior threatening and arrogant it
wasn't just rude it was way beyond that
and what concerned me most it was
threatening to the jur jury and I see
that they do this stuff you know what
I'm this is the
Joker Joker qu Phoenix as the Joker this
is a a joker without makeup same level
of Comedy too so you want to hear
someone more awful than I do Monahan's
Council his lawyer oh God K driver she's
like a driver not mini driver driver K
driver begins with k driver her client
has been on painkillers and that made
him too
relaxed I had a feeling this I was like
this he might be this is like a guy with
diabetes maybe he had ISS right he took
the wrong medic the woman on the plane
was like relax doesn't work but here's
where it continues adding that he
believed the person on the jury was
someone he had gone to school with and
pointed him out to his friend that
[__] ain't real remember that
woman on the
so this that's what she's claiming this
is one of those moments driver driver
said Mo apologizes for his language and
behavior adding he realizes now that he
that could be very in once you realize
that a punishment this is your friend
once you realize that he could get
actually punched in the face once a fist
came close to him he's like I don't want
this anymore I don't want this anymore
here it is despite fears that the trial
might have to be abandoned due to them
feeling intimidated the panel later
convicted two men including the
Mastermind of a fake designer clothing
scam who ran one of the UK's largest
ever Carousel tax frauds I want to find
I want you to tell me number one how
much was the case the tax fried tax Cas
in pounds Cas in
pounds how much we're going to have to
buy a converter for this well I mean
whatever but I say 10 million pound I
was going to say 10 million pound there
you go you all right they B attemp what
do you
say 65 million pound how about 150
million PB that's so many pounds and
we're going to get out of here on this
before you toss it to ran how old is
Michael moan the guy in the construction
no way this guy's under 50 a
construction worker I'm going to say4
who lost a leg 61 5461 41 41 get your
answers in and then Randy will do a
little tease on uh Story number three
story number oh no I have a story number
three for no it's me no you're in a
different dock because that's right
that's right that's right uh guess how
old 31 years old 31 years old young that
guy's lived a life 31 to leg Yeah
construction worker lost his leg
intimidating people going to jail wit
lot lot of stuff going on crazy story in
court Story number two Down Chris
estratas with us his show this fool is
unbelievable on Hulu you guys should be
watching and then go check him out live
wherever you can follow him on social
media we'll come back uh do what we have
going on on Story 3 it's D people tell
with Chris Str we'll be right back
around
hey guys welcome back to the show before
we get into segment three want to remind
people not sure exactly when this drops
but Randy and I beginning of the new
year beginning year January 4th we're
going to be in Portland at Helium I love
that CL one night only let's it out
let's go Port let's sell it out and then
the next night we're at the crocodile
the 5th of January love that club part
of the wet City Comedy are you guys
doing an AM Northwest when you're in
Portland oh I don't know maybe oh yeah
we might we should we absolutely should
Sten Helen yes I love those guys we
absolutely should because we're getting
in the night before and doing a private
thing so then and I become buddies if
out or I can reach out to him but we
need it cuz we want to sell that we want
to sell that out and then uh beginning
of uh February we're back in Denver at
Comedy Works I'm sure you've been there
I love we're at the South Club which I
love too it's both clubs are amazing
Southtown amazing we had great shows
last time want to do the same this time
uh Mark Ridley's Comedy Castle at the
beginning of March and then uh AC and
Minneapolis the beginning of April moon
tower at the end of April and then we'll
see maybe Alaska in May and then future
stuff down the line I really want to get
back to the Bell house and do a live
down people town we just when do you
want to do it we'll figure it out we'll
figure it out on let's if we can attach
it to something spring or summer maybe
we'll do it I love the Bell house so
much and we'll be back there and Keenan
Thompson said he'd be a part of that one
so I know that was great we'll do that
anyway good stuff happening suers
scar.com you can check all that stuff
out and if this is before Christmas if
it drops then uh Daniel vankirk and I
did a little thing in the Keenan
Thompson Kevin Hart end of the year
special on peacock that J back that year
up
2023 on the 26th and it'll probably just
exist on peacock after that you can
watch it whenever you want great holiday
watching it's a really fun show I got to
see some of the other stuff like like
early segments and interviews and stuff
like that and it's just a great fun show
those guys clips and jokes and
characters and really fun good stuff all
right shall I jump into this final story
sent in by Guess Who Caren mcder at shei
Caren so fans is the way to do it uh
Chris is our fans can just we're still
on X still on Twitter @ slar Brothers
Danel trying to use threads more I like
threads I I needed to get a little bit
better with this like search
optimization so and maybe eventually we
jump over maybe we jump over threads but
right now it's it's on you just at Dan
Kirk at slar Brothers hashdump people
toown send us the story you guys have
been doing great we are so I mean I'm
like in August right now looking for
stories and it's we have a backlog but
here we go I'm read you the uh headline
this is just a fun little story Dutch
police arrest quote Boris Johnson for
drink driving incident drunk driving
incident suspect had fake driver's
license with the prime minister's photo
and date of birth so this is not Boris
Johnson prime minister this is someone
else claiming to be Boris Johnson trying
to get this dude a DUI and the Dutch
have just uh elected like the most
far-right guy ever so it's like what
like I'm sure they're just going to
start throwing in jail now Dutch police
arrested a man in a drunk driving
incident over the weekend and discovered
that his driver's license named him as
Boris Johnson the fake Ukrainian
driver's license why we got to bring
Ukraine into this yeah yeah why they're
going through a lot they are really
going through a lot can we not have them
in like driver's license scams here
complete with the former British prime
minister's picture and correct birthday
so it didn't when did you have a fake ID
growing up I had a fake idea growing up
okay where it say got it here in LA in
MacArthur Park there you go you took it
outside took the photo outside took the
photo uh in an apartment they had an
apartment set up and were you like I'm
going to someone's apartment I don't
know what's going to happen to me yeah
well if you go down there at Marth you
can get anything in MacArthur Park here
in downtown Los Angeles over in West
Lake and you somebody just if you kind
of walk around somebody eventually we'll
say in Spanish they'll go mikas which
means like fake ID amazing you and I'm
like let's go I was like 18 at the time
I want get to bars I need you were 21 or
did you push it up a couple years or no
I think yeah I pushed it up till like it
was 24 okay yeah yeah I mean that's
great I mean we had an old bit so we
were one of our first stand up bits one
our first stand up BS ever like some guy
built a huge in our fraternity built a
huge board for the Kentuck for a
Kentucky driver's license and we took
our picture outside on the roof of the
house cuz he's like the lighting is
better outside we're like I don't think
we should be outside what Drive sure you
know should leaves be blowing through
the photo back yeah right there's a dog
catching a frisbee behind my head I
don't think that's ridiculous all right
so the fake Ukrainian driver license had
Boris Johnson's picture on it you either
better look like Boris Johnson yeah why
would it be who's dumb here the person
who wanted it or the person who made it
or is he trying to get Boris Johnson in
trouble yeah picturing correct birth
date was issued on July uh 24th 2019 the
date he moved into 10 Downing Street you
know so this is like he's moved this is
the day he moved in as UK's leader and
is valid until the year you want to
guess when this thing is valid to on
this it's probably only supposed to be 5
years so what do you think this in 2019
so 2024 what do you think 2029 what do
you think I'm going to say even crazy
I'm going to say like some 2030 or
something uh how about the year 3000
that's how you know this [__] is fake is
this Conan O'Brien it's the year 3000
all right police
spokesman I might GNA get this right th
JS how would you pronounce that t i Js
th
th yeah th damstra said uh officers
investigated the incident shortly after
midnight Sunday when a car crashed into
a pole near the Emma bridge in the
northern city of granigan the car was
Gran again the the car was abandoned but
the police later told the driver was
standing on the bridge so definitely
this guy's drunk or smoked too much weed
it is answer is it is Dutch okay the
person could not identify himself and
refused to undertake a breath lizer test
damster told him and this was the ID
that he the Boris Johnson I I'm going to
be honest I can't tell if that looks
great or bad it looks like Boris Johnson
yeah but I mean like does it look like
it Blends together it definitely doesn't
look like it was taken in the DMV no it
looks like a photo taken in Boris
Johnson's office outside he's like I
mean he's washed out yeah he always has
Flyway very sunny he's washed out watch
that this image was taken from the
Instagram account of the Netherlands
police grunt so they put that on there
uh gring Centrum on May 1st 2023 shows
the official holding Ukrainian driver's
license featuring image of Boris Johnson
in Gran after a driver was arrested the
item was recovered from his vehicle how
old is this we can get that at the end
from a small town in Zed horn west of
grag again so this is a Dutch guy with
this driver's license was arrested what
if he looks exactly I'm like most Dutch
people I have a Ukrainian driver's
license and
it's that's what mine is Van Kirk but I
go with the the Dutch thing all right
inside police found fake driver's
license belonging to Boris Johnson
unfortunately for this person we we did
not fall for this forgery this is the
police and gr again being like little
cheek I mean sorry we didn't we didn't
you think that's the police being funny
yes yeah because of course they who no
one's going to fall for I agree I like
to imagine this was a 19-year-old
wearing a Boris Johnson
maskir cuz he does have like trumpy and
like messed up hair he a lot of times he
looks like Lloyd from Dumb and Dumber
too
yes police could not say where the forge
document was made but former Russia
correspondent
kaisya uh hexter in a tweet published by
the noos said that the fake driver's
license could easily be bought in
tourist shops in Ukraine wait the
Russian person is accusing Ukraine of
doing this that's weird d ask as far as
I'm aware the real Boris Johnson was not
in the Netherlands at the time as far as
I'm aware how old you got to look like
your driver's license FKS right how old
was this guy who was trying to be Boris
Johnson trying to be Boris Johnson
crashed his car into a pole no that was
his fake his fake driver's license how
old is this person I wonder if he's got
a driver's license for when he's like
I'm going to drive drunk let me take my
drunk driver get a fake license doesn't
feel like an old man's game it doesn't
and it also feels imigrant and like you
need some sort of that's why I think
this person is Young And I also think
just the idea that they didn't look that
it was three like The Year 3,000 they're
definitely not checking not dotting the
eyes and crossing the teeth so to speak
I'm going to say early 20s how you 22 22
what do you think because you really
don't need a a dry I'm going to go 36 36
okay 27 one of you yeah is one year off
so now you get to go up or down I'll go
35 35 what are you going to go I'll go
23 23 I'm going to go 28 okay get your
answers in townies the great Chris
Estrada he'll be back we love him in
dumb people town he is the best watch
this fool watch it telling you guys are
going to love it so much send a message
tweet out at Hulu Dan dank.com go see us
super.com see him on the Kevin Hart
special he was hilarious I appreciate
that this man from zud horn west of
gragan in the Netherlands is 35 years
old hey we love you guys have a good one
if this drops around the holidays I hope
you have a wonderful holidays and Oh
Ship we got to get back to work around s
there's